- I actually don't know
what we're doing today.
A lot of face things.
(squealing)
(screaming)
- Do you have a cutting board?
- Nope.
- Oh.
- Holy shit!
I totally underestimated how disgusting
this would actually be.
- Where are we?
- I really do hope this goes
better than the snail facial.
- Ew!
(gong rumbles)
(energetic music)
- We found a BuzzFeed post that has a list
of dermatologist approved DIY facials.
So we're gonna try a couple of those out
before we do the professional one.
Half a teaspoon of lemon juice,
half a teaspoon of baking soda,
and one tablespoon of honey.
- I don't like Daysha
with a knife next to me,
but let's proceed.
Just stay in your little
area, and I'll stay in mine.
- Don't think I won't cut you.
(laughter)
- [Man] All my seeds are going in here.
- You can take the seeds out.
- I want 'em in.
- Oh, fuck. (laughs)
The tab, well, it ripped off.
(loud thudding)
- Holy shit! (laughter)
- Got it!
- There's a mirror. (laughter)
- If it helps,
you actually do look
totally stupid right now.
(groaning)
(laughter)
- It actually does feel pretty soft.
It doesn't feel bad.
It just feels, feels a
little clogged up with honey.
- The honey's just a little too sticky.
- You cut this avocado.
We each get half of an avocado.
- You got it.
- This isn't ripe.
(laughter)
- Oh!
- Things have gone horribly wrong.
- Jesus Christ.
(sloshing)
(laughter)
- Tilt your head back a little.
- Fuck it.
(groaning)
- Jen, you look amazing!
What's your secret?
- DIY.
(laughter)
- You asshole.
- I feel like you're doing a
better job at this than I did.
(sloshing)
But maybe not.
- No, come here.
I'm doing you.
(screaming)
- I thought this one was dope.
I felt like it actually,
really like cleared up my skin.
My skin feels really soft right now.
- It was nice, like slapping
it in your face though.
That was fun.
- Your skin will feel smooth,
revitalized, and tingly fresh.
- So we mix a small
amount of water with this,
in our palms and then
we apply it to our face.
- See this one's nice to put on my face,
because I'm not worried.
It doesn't feel gross, and it smells nice.
- It feels like it's eating my skin,
but in a good way.
(disgusted groaning)
- You all right?
- Taste is disgusting.
- Well don't eat it.
- I didn't mean to.
- It feels good.
I just feel very dry.
- It felt very refreshing to take it off.
- Yeah, mine too.
- Yeah, it was very soothing.
- I would do the seaweed mask again.
I would not do the DIY,
the two DIY disasters that proceeded it.
- You know in retrospect,
we prolly shouldn't have
done three masks in a row.
- Well, you know, we do
whatever we want around here.
- That's true.
(energetic music)